the twine it was a nocturnal dignity
good angieland me properly
yesterday but I Jennifer
assalam-o-alaikum a dementia later
catcher Bob decision and dear friends
welcome to another video
I'm healed by the hoodie this one theme
on channel flower is the sound that he
makes the sound effects Donna if you
remember that yeah and okay so we're
going to do is we're going to react to
the video let's watch it this watching
Charlotte and see what it's about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now reaction video something within
reaction is just like watch a video in
the oz bottle or stop crying now I saw
this really is all this is [ __ ]
attention here what is your reflection
when you see that I personally for you
when you first saw it as well when I
first saw it awful he's resigned view
for you yeah yeah and an initially awful
my man right it's just probably learning
because it's probably squeezing it's
just too much the guy in vocal yeah and
he did kind of like do I teach him for a
second year yeah so when I first was
sorry I didn't know he's good I mean it
ever cross your mind that this is what's
about to happen ignore me I just walk
it's beautiful yeah and I'll just like
you know in exactly my surah maybe
another I can listen to save it but what
happened after like to you personally
what kind of a session is given to you
and run your life or just any headed to
change anything fellas it just um to be
honest awful you know what and if you
can happen anytime hmm yeah I mean but I
could die right now yeah I'm the chef
here I'm pretty sure he wasn't prepared
for that by yeah that does not even wise
reciting I mean we can talk about how
lucky is and laugh yeah but he went away
while deciding exactly but you know
what's more profound yeah and I didn't
show you this year now the first thing
that comes on when I see stuff like this
is okay what was he was eyeing it in you
get it what would you say okay it's good
like obviously like that much a
beautiful voice yeah but look at what I
saw psychically when I find this out
about goosebumps here and I'm not even
exaggerating cause it came to mind I was
that come on what was he saying and
look-wise reciting I didn't show you he
who created death and life to test you
as to which of you is best in deed and
he is the exalted in might and the
forgiving yet he
look look I feel like this is mind
blowing here and he basically and
spoiling you'll also find that if my
chest was high
mmm like I'll just maybe just stop and
panic and just let the person that
planes going on yeah if you notice he's
carrying on his curly look even though
his mumbling is actually carry on I
would like the shows but Quran that so
installed in him the and he's dying he's
just kinda not well I am because I don't
know yet
but me passed out just be like yeah I'll
have to stop it well tell somebody he is
just carrying on a key term on casually
what like he's amazing and this and this
verse acting what's your reaction that
as well he who created death and life to
test you as to which was used the best
indeed don't tell me that's confidence
like do young Tennessee if you live your
life based on his family what does that
give them a nice understand
nobody's saying look leave this life
completely
yeah all you have to do is the hair off
normally saying that yeah we're not here
tonight to depress you and just what
would you say look this is a reality
yeah and in one of my reaction videos
let me just show you is let me quickly
show you this I did add FX per minute
you know what we do is offer the clip
there is there's a mirror he's looking
directly at the mirror you know we say
this is that this is you right now if
you look in the mirror she we're going
to show you a picture of you in the
future so turn around a little kept us
the tips of Alaska yeah mmm he'll react
ah ah enemy not gonna get
survivor now why that oh wait oh wait oh
sorry came it's all about but forgive
colleagues you know that yeah oh wait I
did ones on tonight
cool say or do you ever think about this
from it anyway like that's one thing
twice anyway okay so it's all show me
don't put the camera face what why shall
we are you coming up to me channel my
hero okay I paired is an experiment okay
look what was the last important like
what muscle saw something yesterday him
yes I think actually reacted and look at
the way look he was on camera he knows
our camera he's done an absolute mad one
so as human beings we live like
afterward only creatures on this
deliver they know gonna die tomorrow and
when we are reminded of death
I beg you so many people are going to
avoid watching this yeah just because
that just because they don't wanna you
know I'll do the same result from yes
all right
yeah no nobody said okay it is my death
every now and then it's good yeah
and suppose I don't long it out but like
I said before I just want to shave one
verse of you guys like I said before in
the Quran in chapter 4 so knees over 78
wherever you may be death will overtake
you even if you should be within towers
of lofty construction but if good comes
to use them they say this is from Allah
etc etc so guys we can't run away from
this as much as we Mac yeah it's going
to find us the man who is wise or the
woman who's wise would think of hardware
prefer fella you know and you would die
the way you live and meaning what else
come to my original point is that look
practice your religion as much as you
can you dying in a state of meaning what
will mean is don't die in a state of you
was clubbing and he was drunk and
whatever it may be
god knows what he's doing yet what we're
seeing is yes we all give us a death
like that insulite cetera however
nobody's saying that you have to die
like this and to say okay much are
you're definitely safe know what we're
seeing this look for it's not imagine
you died in your plate mullet good play
just all laughing you did to miss your
Salah this what we're trying to say you
died I mean was recycle around for
example or do you die when using an act
of charity yeah
so what you trying to say one other
thing you have to be that that you can
be that them but nobody thing you have
to be like a big big chef you should
aspire to but do you open what you can
do even charity tell people imagine
what's keeping the neighborhood a person
and you passed away today I'm trying to
say so that's about it guys for me I'm
bhava or he may be might have been more
on the show in show in any last words
anything you wanna say oh not really to
be honest but even this reaction video
doing this you actually made me think
the wrong yeah it's awesome all right
now unless you may be broken me I love
this every single one of you guys as la
moneda wat metal like that affair to
from us and Iman channel watch them on
Sky eight five seven
well no not yeah
I mean even a Latino and Latina meet a
yellow
Oh